thanks to hunting clash for sponsoring
this video find out more later on hey 42
here sweat glands are a bit like
politicians
nobody likes them but you have to admit
they do do important work work like
getting rid of toxins banishing heavy
metals
and generally keeping you cool that's
sweat glands not politicians at least
not in my constituency but it turns out
there's an awful lot more to your sweaty
secretions than detoxing and stopping
you from dying from heat stroke in fact
our smelly pits and glistening foreheads
are the unsightly by-products of an
evolutionary adaption that help does
humans become the dominant species on
planet earth
hunting clash is an awesome progressive
hunting game available on android and
ios that's free to play by clicking on
the link in the description below
it's packed full of breathtaking
locations that offer a variety of
testing hunting conditions
i found namibia particularly challenging
due to the sandstorms blocking my shots
there's also a huge selection of rare
location-specific animals hunting clash
is fast-paced in fact it doesn't take
long to start levelling up and unlocking
new regions and challenges the best way
to rank up fast is to improve your
precision the animals are all different
sizes and some are much faster than
others so you need to be able to keep up
with them and to aim quickly to get the
perfect shot my favorite part of the
game is jewels a pvp game mode that puts
your sharp shooting skills against other
players in a head-to-head hunting master
class also just my little tip don't
forget to constantly upgrade your weapon
even a 2
accuracy improvement can be the
difference between a win and a loss so
if you fancy yourself as a bit of a
sharp shooter and you think you've got
what it takes to out-shoot me
then download hunting clash today using
the link in the description below happy
hunting
sweat is made from the watery parts of
our blood and it contains a unique
cocktail of molecules that act as
markers for our sex our health our
emotional state and our diet
since sweat starts out life as blood any
chemicals that are circulating through
our veins can in theory end up in our
sweat as well that makes sweat analysis
a good way of determining whether or not
someone is under the influence of drugs
or alcohol and plenty of other things
besides
one nurse in south africa managed to
turn her sweat red for her
self-proclaimed fetish for red pigmented
spicy tomato corn chips
markers for diabetes organ failure and
various cancers can also be found in our
sweat and sweat monitoring could bypass
the need for invasive blood tests in
medical diagnoses our bodies release
sweat through two types of gland echoing
glands and apocrine glands
eccrine glands produce the salty stuff
that drips from our pores when we work
out or get too hot and they're found
pretty much everywhere now i know sweat
has a bit of a bad rep but it's a lot
more dignified than the solution several
other animals have found to the problem
of overheating stalks and vultures for
example
crap all over their own legs to keep
cool pit stains may be embarrassing
but you have to admit they're better
than stains
sweating is one of our secret
superpowers it may be less glamorous in
our big brains tool use and language but
our ability to stay cool is what allowed
us to run hunt and generally survive on
the hot african savanna when our sweat
evaporates it takes heat energy from our
bodies along with it stopping us from
overheating
having only two legs puts us at a bit of
a disadvantage when it comes to
sprinting
but when it comes to distance running
the power of sweat gives us the upper
hand we may be tortoises compared to
many of nature's natural hairs but there
aren't too many animals out there that
can run extreme distances anywhere near
as fast as we humans can eventually
nature's sprinters get too hot and
either die from heat stroke or need to
stop to cool down we on the other hand
can maintain a steady pace for miles
our ancestors as well as a few modern
hunter-gatherer tribes used this ability
as part of a strategy known as
persistence hunting
slowly wearing down much faster prey to
the point of exhaustion
humans have a uniquely high density of
sweat glands and we produce around 400
to 700 milliliters of the stuff every
day if you live in a hot place it could
be as much as several liters
just one square inch of skin contains
around 650 sweat glands
which is 10 times more than even our
closest chimpanzee relatives we aren't
the only ones who use evaporation to
keep cool though hippos for example
produce an oily red secretion on their
skin which also acts as a natural
sunscreen and antibiotic horses are one
of the only other animals to perspire as
profusely as we do which is probably why
they can outrun humans over long
distances although having said that
humans have won the annual welsh 22 mile
man vs horse race on two separate
occasions
my we brits really do love a weird sport
don't we how much you sweat depends on
your size sex fitness genetics and even
how hot the climate was where you grew
up it's no surprise that overweight
people tend to produce more sweat
because they have more trouble losing
heat than thinner people but
paradoxically fitter people usually
sweat more often too
that's because muscle produces more heat
than fat and if you're constantly
exposing your body to high intensity
workouts it learns to remove excessive
heat more efficiently in other words
more sweat our diets can have a huge
impact on our sweat
not only in terms of its composition but
also how much sweat we produce ever
wondered why you sweat when you eat
spicy food
that's thanks to a pesky molecule by the
name of capsicum which reacts with
temperature receptors in your mouth to
trick your brain into thinking you're
overheating
hot food and drinks also stimulate our
sweat glands
and if you're opting for a coffee the
caffeine in your drinks makes you drip
even more
for some people excessive sweating is a
real problem whether it's due to an
overactive thyroid the menopause
diabetes anxiety or their genes others
struggle to sweat at all making them
vulnerable to heat stroke
but while sweating is important for
keeping us cool the whole
sweating detox theory is a total myth
yes sweat does contain small amounts of
heavy metals and pollutants but to have
any significant impact on the
concentration of those toxins in your
blood
you would have to sweat out pretty much
all of your blood plasma which would be
great from a detox perspective but would
also come with the minor downside of
causing you to shrivel up and die
while sweating can't offer the total
body cleanse you might have hoped for
its importance in our revolution
shouldn't be underestimated for example
it's likely that we lost most of our
body hair to maximize the area from
which our sweat could evaporate but then
why did we keep any hair at all it's
thought that the hair on our heads helps
prevent our brains from overheating when
you're on two legs your head gets the
biggest hit from the midday sun our
eyebrows were probably useful for
communication and along with our
eyelashes we're able to protect our eyes
from sweat wind and other debris but
what about the hair in our crotches and
armpits how the hell did that stuff get
us an evolutionary upper hand well to
answer that question we need to take a
look at a second type of sweat gland
have you ever been on your way to an
interview or a date and felt an
unwelcome sweaty surge in your underarms
you have your apocrine glands to thank
for that
these glands produce a fatty and often
smelly secretions that emanate from our
armpits and groins from puberty onwards
and they respond to stress pain and
arousal in other words they produce
emotional sweat
our echoing glands respond to these
things too as anyone who's ever suffered
from sweaty palms will know but it's
armpit sweat that tends to cause the
most concern having said that sweat
itself doesn't smell the smell we
associate with sweat is actually the
smell of bacteria farts
allow me to explain
we tend not to worry too much about
getting stinky shins or elbows and
that's because the watery sweat from our
echoing glands contains a lot of salt
which makes it really hard for bacteria
to flourish in those areas
apocrine sweat on the other hand
contains less salt and more of the tasty
fats and amino acids that skin bacteria
love
nestled in the warm moist nirvana of our
skin folds bacteria feast on those
molecular morsels and release sulfurous
digestive gases in the process
that might sound gross
okay it is kind of gross
but our unique body odors allow our
bodies to communicate important
information about our identity health
and emotions
for example we tend to be more put off
by the smell of someone fighting an
infection compared to healthy body odors
which helps us to naturally avoid people
who might make us sick
smell can be an indicator of
non-infectious diseases too
smelling bitter can be a sign of liver
damage smelling sweet could indicate
diabetes and smelling fishy might mean
you have a metabolic disorder called
tremofilamenoria which is when your body
is unable to break down certain proteins
our lifestyle can have a big influence
in our sweat as well eating too much red
meat can make you smell of rotten eggs
and if you drank too much of an evening
you're likely to have a lingering
tequila-like tongue the following day
the secrets in our sweat can reveal much
more about us than whether we've just
been on a bender though those of us with
particularly sensitive noses can smell
emotions
especially fear seriously whilst most of
us don't know it we can distinguish
between the smell of sweat from someone
watching a scary movie and someone
watching a nature documentary although
some of those nature docs can get pretty
intense too
the smell of fear is contagious and in
one study volunteers who smelt the sweat
of nervous skydivers showed an increase
in neuronal activity in fear-associated
regions of the brain in fact our odor
can be so overpowering that it almost
completely masks our natural scent and
experiments have shown that whilst
people going into an interrogation room
all carry their own unique aromas they
all come out smelling pretty much
exactly the same
our smell can even give away aspects of
our personalities when presented with an
array of smelly t-shirts
women can recognize dominant male
personalities or even tell if a man is
single from his sweaty scent alone in
general single men tend to have stronger
bo than those in relationships which is
thought to be linked to the higher
levels of testosterone they produce
compared to most partnered men or maybe
single men just have lower standards of
hygiene which might be why they're
single in the first place
stronger bo doesn't necessarily put
women off though a derivative of
testosterone found in male sweat called
androstedenone is fought to increase
female arousal improve women's moods and
even alter their hormone levels
and although women are generally more
sensitive to their partner smell than
men
the unconscious male brain can still
glean information about a woman's
fertility from her smell alone
and men are often more attracted to
women at the most versatile stages of
their monthly cycle so why are we not
all attracted to the same smells and the
same people for that matter well it
seems that some of our preferences
actually come down to our genes
particularly those involved in our
immune response
the major
histocompatibility complex or mhc
is a large highly variable region in our
dna that allows our immune system to
recognize our own cells and fight off
any invaders
the same region also has a big influence
over how we smell and it turns out that
most women prefer the smell of men with
dissimilar mhc regions to their own
which makes sense because if you have a
different immune system to your partner
your children are likely to be more
resistant to infections
having said all that although women
appear to be able to sniff out partner
compatibility with the proficiency of a
police sniffer dog on the trail of a
meth head
men don't seem to exhibit the same
immune profile preferences and neither
do women on hormonal contraceptives
in fact if anything women on the pill
tend to prefer men with similar mhc
genes perhaps because of the pregnancy
mimicking hormonal changes caused by
this medication
that's because if you're pregnant it
makes sense for you to want to hang out
with your close relatives because
they're more likely to help you with
raising your children than a random
stranger we've been pretty
heteronormative here so far but there
also seems to be some link between
sexual orientation and our response to
smell
for example
homosexual men and heterosexual women
react in the same way when they smell
chemicals isolated from men's armpit
sweat and homosexual women show similar
brain activity to heterosexual men when
inhaling certain female fragrances
although whether this is down to innate
preference or previous experience is
hard to tell
the role of smell in physical attraction
has inevitably been snapped up by the
online dating market thanks to what i
can only describe as one of the greatest
inventions of the 21st century
for the small fee of just 25
you can
find your match through mail order smell
dating service
yeah if for some strange reason you
don't like the sound of smelling
strangers on the internet you can always
partner up in person at a pheromone
party where participants anonymously
exchange smelly t-shirts until they find
the perfect smelly match
if sniffing dirty t-shirts isn't the
perfect way to kick off a lifelong
totally not weird relationship
then i don't know what is
so
is love truly in the bo infused air
maybe but there's one problem
we still haven't found concrete evidence
that human pheromones actually exist
true pheromones are like hormones that
act outside the body and produce a
predictable physiological response
amongst all members of a species
so although your partner's smelly
t-shirt might relax you or really turn
you on the same response can't be
guaranteed from everyone else who takes
a whiff
that said our sense of smell is still
extremely important when it comes to
close relationships and people who've
lost it often complain about a lack of
sex drive and general problems in the
bedroom but here's an interesting
question if our body odors are so
important why do we collectively spend
billions of dollars every year doing
everything in our power to cover them up
by killing the bacteria on our skin
deodorants prevents skin microbes from
breaking down the chemicals in your
sweat
whilst antiperspirants literally block
your sweat paws and prevent the stuff
from getting out in the first place
meaning you probably have to go pretty
deep into the dating rabbit hole to find
out your prospective partner's true
smell and by then it's probably too late
by muting our smells we might also be
muting the chemical communications
that tell other people when we're sick
scared or single who knows perhaps our
obsession with hygiene products is
preventing us from finding our soulmates
and is behind rising divorce rates and
decreasing sexual satisfaction is it
time we all started a global ditched a
deodorant revolution
nah
thanks for watching
thanks again to hunting clash for
sponsoring this video
don't forget to use the special link in
the description below to download and
play hunting clash today
you won't regret it